Hello, welcome to Smart List. I am Jason Bateman, one of the less smart hosts. Even less smart is Will Arnett and truly dumb is Sean Hayes. We each have invited, well, one of us invites a guest per week. The other two don't know who that person is. Some of it's going to be funny. Hopefully you won't cry and hopefully you learn a little something. So let's get started. Well, here's the sad part. You have Chumba Wamba on your thing ready to go and it's not a joke. No, it's a ringtone. He's getting a call, I think. I've been going so Chumba Wamba heavy lately on the, I keep going like mid conversation all of a sudden, we'll say something and I'll just go, you know, the thing about me is I
get knocked out, but I get up again and she's like, but between that and my 10 year love affair with figuring out who let the dogs out. Right. Oh, but what about that? What's that crap ass band? Well, actually, I've never heard their music, but they're God damn name, uh, bony bear, bony bear. Yeah. It's bony bear. First of all, bony bear is a great band. So is it what? Hang on. B-O-N-E-Y and then, and then V-A-R or something like that. Yeah, that's what it is. You fucking idiot. What's a bony bear? Like what? There'll be like a bat there. Wait, what song are they singing? Why? It's B-O-N and then, uh, space, I-V-E-R. Oh, he likes it because it's French
and he's like, I can speak French. It's not French. He's from fucking Wisconsin and it's this guy, uh, Justin Vernon and my friend, Chris Messina, who works the band and like it. Oh, then they're great. I don't know where a guest is, but I, but I guarantee you that they like bony bear. I have this feeling. How much do you want to bet? How much do you want to bet? Do you want to do a real bet? Wait, I what? 100 Canadian dollars. Sean, do you know who this is? So you can't chime in. 100 Canadian dollars right now. Great. So it's a $5 bet. Is that what you're saying? You know what, dude, that's so insulting. That's so insulting to me and to all my Canadian brethren who I'm going to publish. I'm going to put
your address online. Oh, right on. Right on. Well, just give her. Wait, can I tell you guys something that I was, Scotty and I were watching. Hey, were you just changing your diaper? What did you just pull out from your pants? Why do you wear a Pashbina as a diaper? Cause it was, it was cold. Now it's hot. I was watching field of dreams last night. I've never seen a movie. Okay. Hold for applause. What are you doing? Okay. No, it was really good, but I mean, it's kind of a long way to go to tell a story about playing catch with your dad, but I get it. It was sweet. You know, Scott, he's like, you know, all these people wanted an Academy Awards. I don't know. They were nominated or something.
And then we started having this conversation about who would we conjure up from the past that like, if you could, who would that be for you guys? Who would be, who would it be if, Hey, listen, Jason played catch with his dad at home. And by his dad, I mean the security guy at Fox and by cat, I mean smoking butts behind stage five. But look, yeah. Oh God. All right. Well, we'll get to that later. Sean, who are you so rudely keeping waiting? Yeah. On our little podcast today, we have a gorgeous woman inside and out who we all know we're all friends with. Really? And we all love. She is a light guys. Her lineage is filled with all kinds of famous people. I'm trying
to build even the slightest bit of anticipation because you're going to know who it is. Let me try it with this one, this random thing. She graduated college with a degree in photography. Can you guess who that is? Annie Liebowitz. That's it. She's a staple in the history of American comedy. We'll be remembered forever for her many contributions in film and television. She's trending so goddamn hard on social media right now because of her impression of Kamala Harris. It's Maya Rudolph. No way. Come on. Look at this. Oh, pop the cork. Pop the cork.
Oh my God. I was trying to sing Bonny Bear. I'm a stalker. I know something. I'm a stalker. Okay, so wait. Right? How good is Bonny Bear? It's great. I listened to the whole thing and I felt bad for Bateman because he sounded old. I know, identity. And now you look at him. He looks old. That's fucked up. So they're less gross than the name.
They're a person, I think, right? Isn't it a person? It's Justin Vernon pretty much. And he has other guys who are in the band as well. Sean Carey who plays, but they're good friends of mine. They're great guys and they make great music. Hi, Maya Rudolph. Hi, Maya Rudolph. Hi, guys. Thanks for being here.
Sorry for the mood lighting. I'm in a cave. It's the only quiet place at my house. No, I was going to say thank you for the mood lighting. I'm going to join you. It's a wank fest here. Welcome to my jack shack. Yeah, he was talking about that the other day, how you bounce that name off of you. Oh my God. Do you remember I used to say that to you? Did you finally build your jack shack?
He's in it right now. Look at him. I can see it. He's got a smile on his face. And no pantalones. Now, Maya, the reason you're looking for quiet is because there are six, 17 kids. 18 kids over there, right? 18.
Good for you. I like to pop them out. There is nothing elastic about my lower region. Nothing. It's basically like when you get a grocery bag and something has spilled and then everything just falls out of the bottom. So the bottom got too saturated and now it's useless to you. So kids are falling out daily.
Falling out daily. Do your kids love that description of how they came into the world? My son, well, my son thinks that he came out of my butt because he saw like a birth video. So we like to keep it that way. My son said the other day, a little Abel said the other day, he was in the back seat. Archie and I were arguing about the genesis of, this is a terrible parenting, of Grand Theft Auto games and one came first in GTA 5. And Abel's in the back seat going, hey, real quick, could you Wikipedia?
And he cuts me off and he goes, how babies are made? You got it. He's got them in his favorites. It's just a one button. You know, Maya, your husband did describe having a bunch of kids running around the house. He says it's so great. He's a better word. It's like having a fire burning in each room.
It's all warm and cozy. He said that. He said that? Well, he's a bit of a poet. I thought he was going to tell the Jim Gaffigan joke about how it's like, because Jim Gaffigan has five, right? And I think his joke was having a fifth kid is like swimming in a pool and you're drowning and someone hands you a baby. It's a bit overwhelming. I have to say that being in quarantine with four kids is great because I would be very depressed if I was not very busy.
It would be a lot more quiet and depressing. Look at Sean. Yeah, look at Sean. I just got up. Sean is so low right now. He'd have to rally to die. That's how low. How many books is your computer on right now?
Is your computer on it? My computer is actually on a stand right now. But I like to say the books behind me on the shelf. I've read every single one of those jackets. Nice. Oh boy. Nice. Can you say that to Scottie?
I'd say to anybody who'll listen. He says it to all the living members of Chumbo Womba. Maya, are those kids old enough to help out around the house or are they just asking you to help them find things to do? Because that is the only reason Jason had children. Right. I can't keep them entertained. Teenagers, yeah. I've got a 13-year-old and an eight-year-old.
The problem with the teen part is I feel really badly for them because they want to be social. But then I don't want them to be on their fucking devices all day long. But then you've got to talk to them. If they're off the device, then you have to talk to them. It's killing me. And I also feel like... Lesser the two evils is just a thicker data plan, right? Yeah.
I thought you meant dad plan, yeah. Let's let Bateman keep talking and let him hang himself. Keep going, dude, what is it? So one teenager or two teenagers? I have one teenager. She's 14. The others are? I have no idea.
No, 10, 9, and 7. Almost 11, 9, and 7. Is the 14-year-old a nightmare? Has she found her sass yet at 14? No, she's not a nightmare. She's the opposite. So I feel really bad because she's a nice person. That's Pearl, right?
Yeah. I love her. Don't show off, Shawn. You know, we all have Google. Shawn is godparent to all of my children. Is that true? No. Yeah, and like my dad, I've never shown up for them.
Are you guys godparents to anybody? No. I am. I don't even... I don't know what that means. What does it mean? Yeah, I don't know either because I think I failed. Well, we are.
We're actually very active godparents, me and Scotty to Jonah and Sammy. Carrie Aisley's children. You are? Yeah. And so... And we're very active and legally, just somebody in the highly unlikely and hopeful never
happened in case where something happens to them, we are the legal guardians. Right. I don't think that's always the case. It's not a religious thing? No. It used to be a religious thing. And I think now it's much more of a just sort of a custom thing
that you do. And, babe, and listen, should we be godparents to each other's kids just out of safety? No, no, no. We're all set. He's good. So I want to send over the paperwork. He's good.
Yeah, yeah, no. Amanda's got it handled, bro. We're all good. I've got a question for Maya. You don't even know what's for dinner. Maya is actually the godparent to Scotty. I am. Does she powder and swaddle him?
Yes. I do. Maya, I have to say a couple of things. One is... I love you too. I do. I really do love you and I miss you. And I feel like I never see you.
I know. I love you too. I don't ever see you. I know. It's wrong. But the... First of all, I have to say the thing that we all know, but not everybody knows, which is that your mom is
Minnie Ripperton, who sang Love in You. I was so surprised that you threw in the lineage thing. These dudes are like, who? What? Yeah, I don't even know Bonnie Varys. Come on. Your grandfather owned all the Wendy's in like Florida or something? Yes.
Isn't that crazy? Hang on. Sidney Rudolph. Free burgers for life? So supposedly my grandfather and his brother were these big time business boys back in the day. And he came up with this idea for a company called Trip Charge, where you could get a card and charge it when you were on a trip.
This was before the credit card was invented. And it was such a great idea that he sold the idea to Diners Club. Way to go, Sid Rudolph. Is Diners Club still around? I don't know. But I guess he straight up gave him the idea for the credit card. So Diners Club was just for restaurants? Is that what it was?
That's a great question. I don't know if it was like a traveler's check situation for going on. I remember those. Travelers checks. Cart Blanche. Remember Cart Blanche was a thing? What was Cart Blanche? It was similar to Diners Club.
I thought it was like, oh, Cart Blanche. And you just say it. Yeah, I liked it. Speaking of the Rudolphs, how was your dad? He's good. Are you asking me about my sweet dad? Isn't my dad the best? He's so sweet.
He's that guy my whole life that people ask me about. I just got another one today. I met, look at Bateman. I don't know your dad. Why don't I get to meet your dad? Her dad is such a cool guy and you would be well-served. This is like the bunny of everything. You'd be well-served to take that scowl off your face.
That's my rest face now. I have a heavy brow. I need a lift. But I am talking a lot about this. I constantly look like I've just said, what did you say? Yeah. That's my rest face. Yeah, mine too.
Wait, are you just coming to terms with this? Just to get to regular, I have to pretend I've just said, oh, I see. Right. That's what I had. That lifts things up to where center is. I think it's from years of being funny and years of emoting and now your skin is relaxing into itself.
I have developed really gnarly eye bags and I think it's from years of rubber face. Me too, Maya. Maybe you and I can find a doctor that can just cinch us up in all the places. Those eyes and vaginas. Yeah. There's probably somebody in the valley somewhere.
They're kind of similar. They're similar areas. Picture eyes and vaginas done here. That's like sham coach and sham poach. Sham poach and sham coach. Sham pooch and sham. Sham pooch and in the back, you get sham pooch. Here's a very dark, dark story.
Before you get into this, I do want to say this. I went on a date with Ali. You went on a date with Ali? Wait, this is. What do you mean? I went on a date with Ali in New York and he took me to see puppetry of the penis. Do you remember that show?
Wait, yes, I saw it in England. It was terrible. Wait, Ali, who's Ali? Ali Farnakian. Ali Farnakian is a funny guy. He's the guy who came up with sham pooch and sham pooch. No, married with a couple of kids. And we used to pass.
And both named sham pooch and sham pooch. And we used to pass puppetry of the penis all the time on the way home on Seventh Avenue. And then we used to also, Amy and I used to always pass and we'd always say to each other that my favorite title for a play of yours, I love you. You're perfect. Now change.
Oh my God. I saw puppetry of the penis. I thought it was going to be like this brilliant thing. It was just guys playing with the dicks on stage. It was so painful and awful looking. A lot of stretching of skin. Yeah. Wait, so there was actual frontal nudity all the way through it?
Yeah. Really? Are they cut or uncut? They were. Well, they're Australian, so. Yeah. So uncut. Uncut.
So snudders. Wait, what? It's a snutter, right? It's called a snutter. I believe so. I've never. If it still has its little turtleneck. I'm a disgusting foul person and I've never heard that term.
What about aardvark? We used to call them aardvark. Yeah, sure. Aardvark is standard. I love the idea that Bateman goes in to get a facelift and the doctor says, no, just do the surprise face more. Yeah. And could you take care of my snuts?
How many snudders do you have? I've got three penises. Sean, I cut you off 10 minutes ago. You cut me off 10 years ago, but that's okay. Hello. No, no, I was just going to tell a story about my mom who passed away like two or three years ago. God rest her soul.
Best mom in the whole wide world. Darkest sense of humor. That's why it's okay to tell this story. She would even laugh at this. And so when she was two years old, she had cancer and they removed her eye, the entire eye out of her socket. I knew that. And it wasn't until she passed away that I found her old medical records
from when she was a kid and realized and learned that they took skin from around her vagina to reshape her eye socket, which was kind of astonishing back then. But, you know, I'd share the story with a friend of mine and he said, wait a minute, you're just telling me this now? The whole time I knew her, I could have fucked her in the eye. I thought you were going to say, I thought you were going to say to her, everybody looked like a cunt.
Oh my God. It's brilliant. That's better than everything I was working on. I had tear duct stuff. It was a lesson. Oh my God. Okay. Okay.
This is- Maya, I'm so sorry. Maya, I'm so- This is an X rated show, right? Yeah, no, we're going to cut that out. So listen- God, that's really funny. So I want to ask you seriously, back to Mini, your mom,
your dad produced that record from your mom, right? Yeah. They wrote a bunch of songs together and stuff. Another common question. I'm sorry, but I think you and your did I get laid. Yes, I did But did you because you have a great singing voice too Did you ever want to do albums and all that and sing and perform like I think the performing part? Yes, but the singing part I knew very early on that I did not have the vocal range of my mother Well, because you were surrounded by music the whole yeah musical, but I don't but I don't have that kind of a voice
I mean when the standard is like a seven octave range. You're sort of like I'm good, but I like I like making music I do like making music. I think now that I'm almost 50. I'll probably start Publicly making music now that I'm not as afraid as I used to be How does one start is it like you start with jingles or yeah, you know like you write songs about lettuce You're like, huh here. We come light and free holding Chris. That's the way it should be Crispy, too. That's right. Bateman Swallow it down From yourself and let us the crispier
My do any of your kids want to do like open their mouths and make sounds that sound like they're very They all seem to want to be filmmakers So that's definitely happening because your husband or your partner is Paul Thomas all of the above He's all of those things and you know and they have iMovie So they make a lot of movies all the time, which is pretty damn cute all four of them. That's great truly when my when Archie was born the night he was born it was a Saturday night and Of course, Amy didn't make the show that night and we were supposed to do a Bronx beat that night You're supposed to do you talk about Amy polar from Saturday Night Live as your ex-wife. Oh, don't forget. Well, your OB died
Our OB died the day before so the day that yeah, wait, what so it was the first time ham was hosting SNL Do you remember so ham was hosting and I was gonna pick up a baby. They were shooting at John ham I shot. Thanks. Sean is like a is like an audio chiropractor Here's the thing by the way, I have to jump in so my sister and all her friends live in Wisconsin and they listen to these Podcasts and she's like, I don't know what they're talking about half the time They're thrown about names. So that's why I'm plugging in all these names because they don't my advice to your sister is move. Oh, yeah Anyway, that's fair enough. That's fair enough. So John ham first time he's hosting so we go and we're gonna we supposed to go to this doctor's appointment and
The OB dies he dies that day. Are you being serious? That's crazy. That's what yeah, so he was old He was very old. Well, why was she seeing a guy on his death's doorstep, but she got a deal on him or something like that You get an OBGYN that that's got a few more years. We're vibrant So anyway, so we go sometimes you want sometimes you want the best you go you go you go to the quality This guy had deliverance. This is not a bit the whole the big thing was he delivered. So feel Lorenz, baby Oh my god, hey, whatever and wow, that was great in like 1950 beautiful, baby. That was a beautiful What a baby, but then apparently he forgot about it, but anyway Look
So so anyway, we go in and Archie is born and we turn on the show that night And he's a couple hours old and Maya sang a song Oh, yeah, Keenan and I Keenan and I sang a song for a little baby Archie. Really live. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, that's so nice I'm nice sometimes John. I really am. Well, that's not coming through Oh, sorry. You are the nicest. I love you to death. You know, I love you too. I want to ask you some more stuff But I can I go to SNL, which I know you're probably sick of talking about but or maybe you're not but I I'm cool. I hosted your first year of SNL I was a host during your first year
Well, I remember and even then I was like as I was hosting I was like who is this Master of comedy this girl. I just I'm who I'm falling in love with So quickly without as much as a date. I remember the facts of life sketch So well that you put up and it was Mrs. Garrett stuck a carrot But and that's why her head so red keeps singing these are the facts of life I can't believe you remember that. That is insane because I couldn't stop singing it afterwards. Missing carrot stuck a carrot up her butt And that's why he also red keeps singing
But it's got it's got it's got it's got it's got a bunch of birth These are the facts of life. It was it was Um wrote that lyric me and Raina got super stoned and rain is a friend of mine and wrote this entire song called the facts of life And it went through rain is a friend of Sean's who's a cook and who's a very good friend of Sean. Sorry keep going That's for Wisconsin All right, so wait so back to SNL so when you were there and I know everybody asked this But for anybody who's not who's never been part of the institution of comedy You know that creates legends like you are now and yes, you are. Thank you Sean. You're welcome. Maya
Everyone always asked I just want to cut him off again because I feel like he might land the plane at some point during the fucking podcast But I did want to say my you are Comedy royalty. Yes to me if anyone was listening to anything. I've said over the last 20 years, I reference you all the time. We'll talk about everybody does a certain level of sophistication and comedy I will say like Maya Rudolph and people go. Oh, I get it. Yes. I swear to God If you're only saying this for me being here today, I do appreciate it. It's so true Maya You know how I feel I you are you are one of the comedy legends of history for true people get it It's a very
Efficient economical way to say. Oh, you would like some smart laughs. Got it. Wow. That's a pretty Large compliment. Thank you my friend. It is absolutely, but I think that what Jason's getting to not only are you known for that? But I will say that as somebody who has worked with you a bunch over the years and and Sean can attest to this too And the three of us did work together as well There is nobody who's quicker or faster or better in the moment and and can eke out Make anything funny even if the scene is terrible and you want to throw it out and then find it in the trash and throw it out again Because it's so bad. Yeah, you have the ability to make every you bring just You always bring the element and this is I think the real the sort of the trademark of somebody's really funny
You always bring in the element of surprise. Yeah, I never know what you're gonna do and it's so every time it's so awesome I always feel yeah, it's exciting doing a scene with you. This is why getting old is great Because we all remember things a lot less than what really happened So your memories all of your memories of our time together are so Part of the intelligence it's night, but honestly, it is nice to appreciate I will I will get honest from it It's nice to appreciate each other as we as we age It's nice to have like it's nice to have had fun together because like my my thing once they started Having kids and having to go to work. I realized like oh, I have to actually like what I'm doing today
Or I'm gonna want to kill myself because it's so depressing when you hate your job and you're you've left your beautiful babies at home so all the time that I've spent with with you guys and In out in the world and doing things I I cherish those times because all I did was laugh my so hard I remember I remember there's this one scene that you and I were in and the show called up all night That will was also in with Christina Applegate and and those are my reference points will and So what network was it on just people don't know this was about the the coke addicts, right? So and Maya you there's this scene where it wasn't quite there yet with just the rehearsal and the writing and us acting And we just were trying I kept saying is it in yeah, right?
And I said I said I said if you can't feel it by now It's never gonna be and you and we crafted the scene in such a way that we finally got it there And then when we shot it you made like to Will's point you made it so funny I couldn't breathe laughing and it wasn't a Halloween thing where we were supposed to be dead or something We're pretending to laugh sorry, but okay, so here's the thing, but now you've accomplished something that you've really did your homework Sean, what's happening? This is the obligation of the host of the person who invites the guests They need to be the adult they need to have the question and the other two idiots get to just throw bombs from the sidelines Well, it's it's it's comforting isn't it it's it's well, but like to your point if you tighten it up it is so
Okay, listen listen to me Now you've accomplished something and I'm now I'm gonna compliment these other two jerks You've accomplished something that even Jason will have accomplished and I wanted to talk about this You all came out of the scene as actors who excel in comedy and and that's kind of what you made made you famous in the world And you all have expanded your repertoire and kind of like crushing the dramatic work as well like I even told Jason on Ozark It's it's the best work. I've ever seen him do it's he's incredible on the show and when he cries I cry very nice of you Thank you because face hasn't changed But you both you both excelled at the drama work too, and I know that's hard to accomplish
But what's really hard to accomplish and you guys have all done it which is to hold on to a sense of where you came from and Acknowledging your comedic roots because I feel that a lot of people who are famous because of comedy Immediately take themselves too seriously and then lose themselves in the journey to prove that they're more than that and in doing so Sometimes they fail. I mean sure you do you know what I mean? I think so. I was guilty of that first season of Ozark I had the the head writer showrunner cut out all the comedy that he'd put wasn't a ton of comedy But there were some things that were and I was like I was so like people have to know that this is this is a this is a drama You know and they're gonna think that there's a it's a comedy because I'm in it. It is a drama Exactly, but like a great writer does throws in moments of levity to you know
And so I got less precious about that in the second season and people really like that about his writing and the third season as well So I got and that was the second season is when they stopped calling you precious on set, right? Yep. Yeah Figured out what was causing it and put an end to it. I was gonna say I mean you guys all know I mean Comedy is just infinitely more difficult than drama over time can to be consistently, you know Funny, it's much harder than well dying is easy comedy is hard. I mean I have to teach them Oh, I did that's why I just read it off my page the truth is that yeah, what I mean what you're saying? Well is what I feel is like it You know at a certain point you realize how They also look comedy and the drama is few and far between and you realize how serious and
depressed you really are as a comedian Internally and then like it it's all kind of part and parcel the same thing So the all the little funny bits make the serious stuff real and it's all kind of I like that movie You did with Krasinski where you guys were it was funny dramatic moments John Krasinski from the office. Jesus. He was on the office he was on the office was God's and Sam and is directed. Yeah You guys that was a great and I I said this when we made our little show flake that not a lot of people saw that was on
Netflix, but I used to say people say is that a comedy drama? I'm like, I don't know when I wake up in the morning. You don't go like today's gonna be a comedy Today's gonna be a drama day. I wanted it to feel like a representation of what a life experience is I mean other than like Mel Brooks's house. I don't know that most comedy households are always funny, right? No, they're probably real quiet. They're probably really dark. Yeah, for sure Now Maya with all the years of experience that you have in the clear understanding obviously of the nuance of comedy as well as drama Do you have any desire to write anything long-form or direct anything long-form and kind of be the person that that Navigates all that stuff directing. No directing
I absolutely don't ever want to do and I think it's the the amount of responsibility that's required that makes me Feel like itchy and hot The like knowing that I have to make sure you've got this covered It's like being the host of a party and making sure everybody's happy like I don't think that's in my nature And I'm and I'm okay with that. That's why I live with the director I don't want to be one but I honestly enjoy the produce cereal side of Giving my opinion putting my time in I mean I I feel like I'm all I'm gonna be a forever writer in the way that I Sort of just like haphazardly became a writer at SNL because they just make you right
我绝对绝对不想去干导演，我觉得那种需要承担的责任感，让我觉得浑身刺挠又燥热。那种感觉就像确保所有事情都在你掌控之中，就像举办派对的东家，得确保每个人都开心。我觉得这不是我的天性，我也接受这一点。这也是为什么我跟导演住在一起，我不想当导演。不过我真的很享受制片的那一面，表达我的观点，投入我的时间。我的意思是，我觉得我永远会是个写手，就像我当年在《周六夜现场》那样阴差阳错地成了写手，因为他们逼你写东西。
You don't have a choice and no one really says hey, you're a writer now. You're just like I'm writing my sketches I don't have a choice and it's really the only way to survive. So I think create can I'll continue to Create what I do, but the directing part. I like to I like to sit down and eat my lunch, you know, I don't Like to be a guest at the party not So stressful and I love When people love doing it and I love to be a part of that But I feel like there was a point in my life where I thought like I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do that And then once I started realizing I don't I'm not good at everything and that's okay
你没得选，而且也没人会说“嘿，你现在是个写手了”。你只会觉得“我在写小品，我没得选”，这真的是唯一的生存之道。所以我想我以后还会继续创作我擅长的东西，但至于导演这块，我喜欢坐下来安安稳稳吃午饭，你知道的。我不想当派对的客人，压力太大了。我喜欢看别人乐在其中，我也喜欢参与其中。但我觉得我人生中曾有过一个阶段，觉得“我要做这个，我要做那个”。后来当我开始意识到我并非擅长所有事，而且这也没关系时——
I'm sort of like yeah, there's no there's no shame in that game My recollection of Maya on a boat night is this like we'd be shooting shooting all day Me like lunch and then her dressing room is next to mine and then like the knock on the door I'd be like, are we still shooting that scene after lunch? I Be feeling the same way. I'd be like, I don't know we bought that little kids. I don't know I was nursing Remember, I was nursing at that like right like the baby was in the room. I was pumping It was
我基本上就觉得，嗯，那游戏也没什么好丢脸的。我记忆中玛雅在夜船节那会儿的场景是这样的：我们一整天都在拍戏，然后吃午饭，她的化妆间就在我隔壁，接着敲门声响了，我会问：“我们午饭后还要拍那场戏吗？”我也会有同感，我会觉得：“我不知道，我们把那小不点儿……我不知道，我在哺乳呢。”记得吗？我当时正在哺乳，对，就在那个时候——宝宝就在房间里，我在吸奶。那是——
Jack was just born Jack. Yeah, he's just turned nine. I want to ask you a serious question I don't know if I'm gonna get through it with my co-host, but here we go. Okay, and you hang on Let me get the stopwatch and go Your mom so sadly passed away when you were younger I think you were six seven eight years old something like that in the wheelhouse. Yes Yeah, and that way house and so and you're an exception incredible mom and it as I've seen firsthand It always seems like your children comes first, which is the correct thing to do and before anything else And you're always present and it's whatever kid wants
杰克刚出生，杰克。对，他刚满九岁。我想问你一个严肃的问题，我不知道我能不能在我的联合主持面前顺利问完，但不管了。好吧，你等等，我去找个秒表开始。你的妈妈在你很小的时候不幸去世了，我想你当时六岁、七岁、八岁左右，差不多那个年纪。是的。对，大概那个年纪。你成了一位不可思议的妈妈，正如我亲眼所见，你的孩子们似乎总是排在第一位，这才是正确的事，排在任何事情之前。你总是陪伴在他们身边，无论孩子们想要什么——
but there's any part of you when you were starting to have kids like and It's it's did you have a one of those real human fears of oh my god What if what happened to me happens to my children and I'm not around is that gonna happen and oh? I'm still not sure that I'm doing this correctly and I get weirded out all the time that I'm 48 and my mom was only 31 when she died and like now what how did I get to be older than my mother? It's so crazy like yeah, I don't I don't know how the hell we're all Adults to begin with let alone responsible for other people and in relationships and families. It's crazy But I what's your perfect ratio?
但当你要开始生孩子的时候，你心里有没有哪怕一点点那种真正的、人类的恐惧，比如“天哪，如果发生在我身上的事发生在我孩子身上，而我不在他们身边怎么办？那种事会发生吗？哦，我还是不确定我这么做对不对”？我总是会觉得奇怪，我都48岁了，而我妈妈去世时才31岁。然后就会想，现在怎么回事？我怎么比我妈妈年纪还大了？这太疯狂了，对吧？我、我不知道我们到底是怎么长成大人的，更不用说去承担起对其他人、对恋爱和家庭的责任了。这太疯狂了。不过，你觉得完美的比例是多少？
Your perfect ratio of work to parenting like like like like what are you doing today aside from this like do you do? That's a great question. I appreciate that question I'm gonna do a little voiceover work later on this afternoon for you working for I'm working for a wonderful production called bless the hearts by our friend Emily Spivey Oh bless the night with and looking for any new characters or Really good damn it was sexy, but also a little bit scary Do with this guy and a little a little bit sad like a little bit like well You know I cuz cuz he's had a few even though it's Wednesday
你工作与育儿的完美比例是多少？就像、像、像你今天除了这个之外还要做什么？你是在工作吗？真是个好问题，我很喜欢这个问题。我今天下午晚些时候要去做一点配音工作，为我们的朋友埃米利·斯派维制作的一个叫《祝福的心》的精彩节目工作。哦，祝福之夜，在寻找任何新角色或者……真的很好，见鬼，既性感又有点吓人，跟这家伙一起，还有点、有点伤感，就像有点像，嗯……你知道的，因为、因为他喝了几杯，虽然今天是星期三。
And he said he wouldn't but he did I thought he was constipated I see sounds a little he had a few sounds like he needs water when ain't no what he was looking He had a few or he's a self-asphyxiated there in the jackshack. Oh boy You know, what's funny? I did write in the time that we've been on this I did write a song for the jackshack and it's called jackshack shagging it up Jackshack you can shake it jackshack Jackshack shagging it up jackshack shagging it up jack get your jack on Shagging it up I wish we had an animated portion of this show. It'd be so good
他说他不会喝的，但他还是喝了。我还以为他便秘了。我听着觉得他有点……他喝了几杯，听起来他需要水，结果才发现他根本不是在找水。他在那个“杰克小屋”里自我窒息呢。哦天哪。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？在我们做这个节目的这段时间里，我真的为杰克小屋写了一首歌，歌名叫《杰克小屋嗨翻天》。杰克小屋，你可以摇摆，杰克小屋。杰克小屋，嗨翻天，杰克小屋，嗨翻天，杰克，搞定你的杰克。嗨翻天！我真希望我们这个节目能有一段动画部分，那一定太棒了。
My used to do this character. She we were gonna do a video and I was gonna be the pop the cork pop the cork And I was DJ Metro. It's just a French rapper And it's just Maya and she's in just like she's in Centro pay and she's in you know, Italy. I like to celebrate We would just say like London Pop the cork Dubai Pop the cork Israel. I want to see you doing all these characters every week again. Damn it I know I should answer your question because you bring something up, which is that I I do Every once in a while go God, I should do that show or I should when we were asking about creating and stuff like oh, yeah
玛雅以前经常演这个角色。我们本来要做个视频，我要当那个“啵的，拔出塞子，拔出塞子”的人，而我是DJ梅特罗，一个法国说唱歌手。这就是玛雅，她当时就在圣特罗佩，在、你知道的，意大利。我喜欢庆祝。我们就会说：“伦敦，拔出塞子。迪拜，拔出塞子。以色列。”我真想看你每周重新演所有这些角色，见鬼。我知道我应该回答你的问题，因为你提到了一个点，那就是我偶尔会想：“天哪，我应该去做那个节目，或者当我问到关于创作之类的事情时，哦，对——”
I should create this and then I'm like, what am I saying? Then I'll never be home. I can't do that But I'm lucky enough to have a lot of talented friends and I'll do like a little bit here and a little bit there and a little bit and that And that's plenty for you. That's plenty Sometimes I spread myself too thin and then everyone so I'll say no now I'm ready to get back in the saddle and do it But I also like to go home sometimes Have you been courageous enough to play with the idea of an empty nest at some point sometime? Deep deep in the future. I say that cuz because I have and it just as much as I am I Love to be out and working. I love my kids
我应该创作这个，然后我就想：“我在说什么呢？那我永远都回不了家了。我不能这么做。”但我也足够幸运，有很多才华横溢的朋友，我就会这里做一点，那里做一点，这样就够了。对你来说这就足够了。有时候我把自己搞得太累了，然后每隔一段时间我就会说：“不，现在我准备好重操旧业了。”但我也喜欢有时候回家。你有没有足够的勇气在某个时刻、在遥远的未来去面对空巢期？我这么说是为了……因为我想过，虽然我很喜欢外出工作，但我更爱我的孩子们。
I love that they are here and I think I'm gonna be a mess when they go to college for sure that times too Right cuz I got two kids you got four Yeah, I'm like when what you know that like when one of the kids isn't home and they're at a friend's house or something You feel like there's no one here. The house is a quiet and it's just strange Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what I'm gonna do But maybe that's a good time to you know move back to New York and start all over again Yeah, there you go see puppetry of the penis with Ali and yeah I just do some sort of a sequel to puppetry of the penis. What would that be called? I?
我喜欢他们就在这里，而且我敢肯定，等他们上大学时我一定会崩溃的，那绝对是……对吧？因为我有两个孩子，你有四个。对，我就像……你知道那种感觉吗？当其中一个孩子不在家，去朋友家过夜什么的，你会觉得这里一个人也没有，家里好安静，感觉怪怪的。对，我不知道，我不知道我要做什么。但也许那是个好时机，你知道的，搬回纽约重新开始。对，去吧，看艾莉和……搞个阴茎木偶戏的某种续集。那会叫什么？我——
Want to go back to the question. I had about come back on that 30 minutes ago What Sean definitely definitely up another real What's number two I want to know because I want to know these things like I know you do and you know it by the way Yeah, good for you. Thanks guys. I know it's very responsible I feel like you brought me in and you're like I have to ask her real questions or she's yeah Otherwise, it's like there's just bits which I love. I don't care. You don't have to ask me anything real Listen, you can ask me anything you want. I love it. And so I want to know how you feel about me No, I want to know so I
我想回到30分钟前提出的那个问题。肖恩，绝对、绝对有第二个问题。第二个是什么？我想知道，因为我想知道这些事，我知道你想，你也很清楚。对，真为你高兴，谢谢你们。我知道这很负责任。我觉得你把我叫来，就像是“我必须问她一些真实的问题，否则她就——”要不然这就只是一些段子了，我很喜欢，我不在乎，你不需要问我任何真实的问题。听着，你想问什么都可以，我很喜欢。所以我想知道你对我有什么看法。不，我想知道，所以我——
Want to know like because way back of 30 minutes ago and I talked about Saturday night live And how you've you've you've helped create that institution that it is Everybody wants to know what was it like getting the gig that you always dreamed of getting like what was it like the first week? Is it like the first week of school and were you nervous and like how did you navigate around that? that was crazy because I came in at the end of the 25th season and I Had this really lame situation where I listened to like a bad manager I was so young and she said don't audition the come the new contracts are really binding and I went, oh, okay I got fucking idiot
我想知道，因为就在30分钟前，我们谈到了《周六夜现场》，以及你是如何帮助塑造了它今天的地位的。每个人都想知道，得到你一直梦想得到的工作是什么感觉？第一周是什么感觉？就像开学第一周吗？你紧张吗？你是如何应对的？那太疯狂了，因为我是25季快结束时加入的。我当时有一个非常糟糕的情况，因为我听信了一个糟糕的经纪人的话。我当时太年轻了，她说：“别去试镜，新合同约束力太强了。”然后我说：“哦，好吧。”我真是个大傻瓜。
And so I didn't audition and then long story short. I was lucky enough They asked me to come and do the last three shows so I did it was more like trial by fire But it was the end of the season so everyone knew each other already It was like it was like joining a school year with three weeks left So like I didn't know anybody and everybody knew where to sit and the cafeteria kind of feeling like it just felt really bad and Scary I didn't know that you did not audition No, so you were you a part of the writing staff and they wanted to put you out then on camera No, it was really confusing. It wasn't clear. They brought me and Zach Galifianakis
所以我没有去试镜，长话短说，我很幸运，他们让我来演最后三场节目。所以我就上了，感觉更像是烈火中考验。但那是赛季末，所以大家都已经互相认识了。感觉就像是在只剩三周的时候转学到一所学校一样。所以我谁也不认识，大家都知道该在食堂哪里坐，那种感觉真的很糟糕、很吓人。我不知道你当时没有试镜？对，所以你当时是编剧团队的成员，然后他们想让你直接出镜？不，这真的很让人困惑，当时并不明朗。他们带我和扎克·加利费安纳基斯——
And I think it was Jerry Minor I think we were the three people That they brought out for these this three week trial period, but Zach and I Didn't know what was going on Zach said they brought he had auditioned and they said like they brought me out But they were just how dishing was a writer and he was really like I don't know what's happening It we were a little bit confused. Did Zach do the show he wrote for three weeks He and I shared an office and we were both like scratching our heads like I didn't know that either What are we doing? Yeah, see you assholes. It's good. I asked questions like that. It is good. You know what Sean?
还有杰瑞·迈纳，我想我们是那三个被带去参加这三周试用期的人。但我和扎克不知道发生了什么。扎克说他们带他……他试镜了，他们说他们把我带过去，但他们只是在试镜编剧，而他当时真的很懵：“我不知道发生了什么。”我们当时有点困惑。扎克也参加了这个节目吗？他为节目写了三周。我和他共用一个办公室，我们两个都在抓耳挠腮，心想：我也不知道这个。我们在干什么？对，看你们这群混蛋。真好，我能问这种问题。确实很好。你知道吗，肖恩？
Great question Sean can you string two together? Well that seems like it's very difficult I can't believe we've gotten to 30 minutes in and we haven't asked you whether you're excited or dreading the whole Kamala Harris for the next probably 12 years Can I just say wouldn't that be a nice problem to have? Oh, God? fucking shit pile of shit of shit mountain that we're living in we just we just had her on the show You did yeah the day before it was announced that she was on the ticket with pretty fantastic. She's awesome
问得好，肖恩。你能把两句话连起来吗？这似乎很难。我真不敢相信我们已经聊了30分钟，却还没问你对于卡玛拉·哈里斯未来可能长达12年的任期是感到兴奋还是恐惧。我能说这难道不是一个幸福的烦恼吗？哦，天哪！我们现在正生活在一堆狗屎山里。我们刚刚才请她上过我们的节目。真的吗？就在宣布她将作为副总统候选人参选的前一天，相当了不起。她太棒了！
She's amazing. There's nothing there that isn't cool. It's like hey, do you want to play a cool superhero like? Yeah, sure. I'm good like You know this, you know, you get to be Batman. It's fun. It's fun to like be a cool person It's what am I gonna know what I'm known for Batman. Oh, you're talking about will yeah But once the that's will calls it the hoax virus goes away You're gonna have to fly back and forth to To New York all the time. Are you going to be happy about that? That's that that could get burdensome I don't know. I really am. I think I'm a little bit in denial of
她太惊艳了。没有什么地方是不酷的。就像是：“嘿，你想演一个酷炫的超级英雄吗？”“好吧，当然，我很乐意。”你知道的，你可以演蝙蝠侠，这很有趣。演一个酷人很有趣。我以后会因为什么而被记住？蝙蝠侠。哦，你说的是威尔。但一旦那个——威尔把这叫做恶作剧病毒的东西消失了，你就要经常飞回纽约了。你会为此感到高兴吗？那、那可能会成一种负担。我不知道，我真的觉得我有点在逃避现实——
What is happening in the world and what's going to happen? I mean, I is there going to be a live show? Doesn't matter. You know what's gonna happen. My let's not play this game. We both I like to play hard to get. You don't have to start wiggling when you say that. I still have my exercise tank on. I haven't exercised yet. I need to take a shower. You don't want any of this. You guys want Chinese chicken salads for lunch everybody everybody Everybody's Chinese chicken salad. Let's get chinchin. I want chinchin. Is chinchin still around? Yes, I get it all the time and it's so fattening. I call it double chins. Chinchin is still the best Just the Chinese chicken salad. I don't think I've ever had anything else. That's the best But you know that the conversation that's happening right now is so Maya will come and do this show
世界上正在发生什么，以及接下来会发生什么。我的意思是，会有现场直播吗？没关系。你知道会发生什么，玛雅，我们别玩这种把游戏了。我喜欢欲擒故纵。你不用在说这话时扭来扭去的。我还穿着健身背心呢，我还没锻炼呢，我得洗个澡。你们才不想要这些呢。你们午饭想吃中式鸡肉沙拉吗？每个人、每个人！所有人都吃中式鸡肉沙拉。我们去买金金餐馆的吧。我想吃金金。金金还在营业吗？对，我经常吃，太容易发胖了。我管它叫“双下巴”。金金依然是最好的，就要中式鸡肉沙拉。我觉得我没点过别的，那个最好。但你知道现在正在进行的对话是这样的：玛雅会来参加这个节目——
She'll come Saturday and then she'll come the next Saturday and so Maya will come That's Will's attempt at Lorne Michael's impression everybody. Wisconsin They don't need to know. Not everybody needs to know everything. Lorne Michael's is my forever boss I just decided the other day like he's my forever boss. He'll always be my boss I'll be my friend, but no matter whether I ever work there again. He'll always be my forever boss Mia, Mia Rudolph. Yes, sir. You've been incredible. It's Mia Randolph Question three. Get ready. No, this is no more questions I was gonna wrap it up because I know you have kids to take care of. Oh, you mean diapers to change?
她星期六来，然后下星期六再来，所以玛雅会来……这是威尔在模仿洛恩·迈尔斯呢，各位。威斯康星。他们不需要知道，不是每个人都需要知道所有事的。洛恩·迈尔斯是我永远的老板，我前几天刚决定他就是我永远的老板。他永远都是我的老板，他会是我的朋友，但不管我以后还会不会去那里工作，他永远都是我永远的老板。玛雅，玛雅·鲁道夫。遵命，长官。你太棒了。这是玛雅·伦道夫。第三个问题，准备好。不，没有更多问题了。我本来想结束的，因为我知道你要照顾孩子。哦，你是说要换尿布？
Yeah, there's no more in diapers, right? You're done with diapers. I'm done with diapers. Yeah So I can't thank you enough for being here and we love you very very very much. I love you very much It was way too short. And even though we Don't get to speak that often. I think about you all the time really like all the time. Yeah Yeah, hey guys, that was so that was so convincing. That was so convincing. Yeah Oh, I do I really do I think about you all the time. You're always such a you're always such a sweet little cookie press Can you sing the Jack Shack Sean one more time? Is that is our sign off? Jack Shack singing it up Jack Shack, it's totally crispy Jack Shack 100% 100% Jack Shack and it's Jack
对，已经没有人在用尿布了吧？你不用换尿布了吧。我不用换尿布了。所以，非常感谢你能来，我们非常非常非常爱你。我也非常爱你。时间过得太快了，尽管我们不常聊天，但我一直在想你，真的，无时无刻不在想。对，对。嘿，伙计们，太有说服力了，真是太有说服力了。对，哦，我是认真的，我真的会的，我一直在想你。你一直都是个这么甜美的小饼干模具。肖恩，你能再唱一次那个“杰克小屋”吗？作为我们的结语？杰克小屋，嗨翻天，杰克小屋，完全酥脆，杰克小屋，100%，100%杰克小屋，这就是杰克——
It's totally crispy Think about it. It could be box of you socks sold separately. I was gonna say this should be a sock sponsor to that Maya super super nice of you. That was really fun. You guys. It's nice to see you It makes this is one of those days where when I'm dying and I'm laying there Shriveled up and then I'll think about today and I'm gonna have a big smile on my face. Oh Like look at that. Love you Maya. You're the best. You're the best You're the best man You're the best. Thank you Maya. Bye guys. It's so nice to see you all. Bye. See you later. Bye
完全酥脆。想想看，这可以是一盒袜子，袜子另售。我本来想说这应该找个袜子赞助商。玛雅，太、太感谢你了。这真的很有趣，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。这是那种日子，等我快不行了、躺在那里枯萎的时候，我会想起今天，然后我的脸上会挂起灿烂的笑容。哦，看那。爱妳，玛雅。你最棒了。你最棒了，伙计。你最棒了。谢谢你，玛雅。再见，伙计们。很高兴见到你们所有人。再见。回头见。拜。
Bye tongues included She winged that song and it's gonna be my head for the rest of the day Jack Shack We were working on Up all night, whatever you ten years ago and she said what did you do this week? And I spent most of the weekend in my Jack Shack And she was so in there she loved that idea. She thought it was the grossest expression And she used to bring it up all the time. She's like, how's your Jack Shack? Hey, is your Jack Shack taking this weekend? I got it on Airbnb now
拜，连舌头一起。她现场即兴唱了那首歌，接下来一整天都会在我脑子里挥之不去。杰克小屋。我们十年前在制作《整夜难眠》或者别的什么的时候，她问我：“你这周末干嘛了？”我大部分周末都在我的“杰克小屋”里度过。她完全融入进去了，她超爱这个主意。她觉得这是最恶心的表达，她以前经常提起这个。她会问：“你的杰克小屋怎么样了？”“嘿，你的杰克小屋这周末要营业吗？”我现在把它挂在爱彼迎上了。
Anyway, I love her we love her. I'm so glad by the way She's the kind of guest that you that we have on that we can just completely be ourselves and fuck around and it's so fun And she could guest host the show with us at any time. Yeah, because she's so funny and so And we love her and know where she's got such an ease and comfort and she's just everything about her is the fucking best I love hanging out with my yes when I I hosted Kimmel a couple years ago and here we go. Yep, and the ratings spiked What is this? I don't even know if sweeps are a thing But I know it was a big deal to Jimmy and it got him a new contract
不管怎样，我爱她，我们爱她。我很庆幸，顺便说一句，她是那种我们可以完全做自己、胡闹却又无比有趣的嘉宾。她随时都可以跟我们一起客串主持这个节目。对，因为她太风趣了，而且……我们爱她，跟她在一起总是那么轻松自在，她的一切都是最棒的！我喜欢和玛雅一起消磨时光。几年前我主持过吉米秀，来了，就是这样，收视率飙升。这是什么鬼？我甚至不知道收视率大月是不是真的，但我知道这对吉米来说是件大事，还给他换来了一份新合同。
I don't even know why I started on this story, but the point is I Needed a guest and I said remember Jimmy Sun was was was in the hospital and stuff and last minute when they were in there And I needed a guest. I was like, who can you count on in a pinch to come in and be funny and available and available? And Maya happened to drive by at that moment. No, and my I called Maya Because yeah, because she's incredibly funny and quick and she saved my ass. She made me look good Yeah, she's always she's always that Jason. Have you ever worked with her? Yeah, she was on SNL The one time I hosted way back when but I would love to and I was serious I have talked about her a lot in anything that I have
我甚至不知道我为什么要讲这个故事，重点是，我需要一个嘉宾，我说：记住，吉米·金梅尔当时在医院什么的，在他们住院的最后关头，我需要一个嘉宾。我就想，危急关头你能指望谁来救场、既搞笑又随叫随到？玛雅恰好在那时开车路过。不，我打电话给玛雅是因为——对，因为她极其搞笑且反应敏捷，她拯救了我的屁股。她让我很有面子。对，她一直、她一直都是这样。杰森，你和她合作过吗？对，她上过《周六夜现场》，就是我很久以前主持的那一次，但我很想（再次合作），我是认真的，我在任何我有——
Half a say in I've always wanted to more and more and more I don't I don't I don't like what the kids are doing to her life And my ability to see her on camera more often So I'd love to talk to her about that. Maybe finding another place for those kids to live would be sure That's for me start you should call Dave Becky and put a light of fire under his ass, you know Well, but maybe Dave could babysit the kids and book her on a couple more things. That'd be great Dave Becky is her manager. Oh, thank you Thanks, Sean. That's my that's my Wisconsin accent. Hey, thanks guys. Don't worry about it. I got it all sorted out
话语权的事情上都经常谈到她。我一直想要更多、更多、更多。我、我、我不喜欢孩子们对她的生活造成的影响，以及这影响了我更频繁地在镜头前看到她的机会。所以我很想跟她谈谈这个，也许给她那些孩子找个别的地方住，那就稳了……那就是我开始的地方，你该给戴夫·贝基打个电话，催促他一下，你知道的。好吧，不过也许戴夫可以帮忙带带孩子，顺便给她多安排几个通告，那就太好了。戴夫·贝基是她的经纪人。哦，谢谢你，谢谢你，肖恩。那是我的威斯康星口音。嘿，谢谢你们，不用担心，我都搞定了。
I just heard Sean said that Dave Becky's her manager. Okay. Yeah, no Sean. Just straightened it out He's straightened out for us out here. Okay, don't worry Dave. I guess he's some kind of Hollywood manager Anyway, great guess. I love her. I love you guys. Bye Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Sean. Bye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我刚听肖恩说戴夫·贝基是她的经纪人。好吧。对，没错，肖恩。他帮我们把这事儿理清了。不用担心，戴夫。我猜他是个什么好莱坞经纪人吧。不管怎样，真是个棒极了的嘉宾。我爱她。我爱你们大家。再见。等等、等等、等等、等等、等等，肖恩，再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。